[MUSIC PLAYING]
The difference between a great
recipe and one that's full of
mistakes is the difference
between a delicious cake and a
complete kitchen disaster.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the case of your DNA, the
recipe that makes you you, it
could be the difference between
life and death.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The DNA code is made up of pairs
of four letters, or base
pairs, A and T, and C and G. But
if things go missing, get
swapped, or the DNA gets
damaged, this leads to
mistakes in the recipe
of life, and
it can lead to cancer.
Your DNA is being damaged all
the time, mostly by the
hurly-burly of processes of
life within our cells
themselves, but also by things
outside the body, by the
chemicals in tobacco smoke, or
UV radiation from the sun.
But luckily, nature has
equipped us with tiny
molecular tool kits that
recognise and repair the
damage, and one of
them is BRCA2.
Found on Chromosome 13, the
BRCA2 gene encodes a large
protein that's responsible
for repairing
damage within ourselves.
But if BRCA2 is faulty or
missing, our cells can't
detect and repair
damage properly.
It builds up, and it
can lead to cancer.
Inherited faults in BRCA2 are
responsible for cases of
breast, ovarian, prostate,
and pancreatic
cancer that run in families.
But rather than being a strength
for cancer, having a
fault in the BRCA2 gene may
actually be a weakness, and
it's one that scientists
are trying to exploit.
Meet my friend Jim.
Now it turns out your cells
have two ways of repairing
damage to their DNA.
One of them is with BRCA2
and a related
protein called BRCA1.
And the other is with a
molecule called PARP.
Yes, PARP.
No sniggering.
If cells have a faulty BRCA2,
they're not so good at
repairing damage to their DNA.
But they can still struggle by,
because they have PARP.
It's like having
their belt cut.
But this damage can build up,
and it can lead to cancer.
Scientists think that treating
these cancer cells with drugs
that block PARP will mean that
they can't repair their damage
at all and they'll die.
It's like cutting the
braces as well.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Drugs that block PARP, called
PARP inhibitors, are already
showing promise in clinical
trials for people with cancer
with BRCA gene faults.
And one day, they may even be
useful for treating cancer in
the general population, too.
But there's a long way to go,
and brilliant scientists
around the world are busy
cooking up new approaches for
treating cancer like this.
But unlike my efforts in the
kitchen, developing new
therapies for cancer isn't
a piece of cake.
[MUSIC PLAYING]